in choir and it's my honor to get to
introduce our speaker this evening I've
covered six sets of Olympic Games for
The Inquirer and it's always an
enjoyable and extremely challenging task
enjoyable because it's an event of such
great scope with so many great athletes
so many things going on all at once and
it's challenging for exactly the same
reasons because there's just so much
going on at once you often feel as the
games are going past year that you're
trying to grab the dandelions as they go
past and just try to grab these great
stories David has grabbed a number of
the great stories in this book and put
them all together for us if you had
asked me which Olympics I would like to
have seen him Chronicle it probably
would not have been Rome just off the
top of my head people what comes to mind
really er the 1936 Olympics in Berlin
the Hitler Olympics the 1972 Olympics in
Munich the tragedy of the Palestinian
athletes or the Palestinian terrorists
in the Israeli athletes pardon me the
1968 Olympics in Mexico City the Black
Power salute of Tommy Lee and John
Carlos the Rome Olympics however great
riders find great stories and that's
what David has done and often is so what
so often happens with riders it's the
story that that chooses the rider not
the rider that chooses the story he was
researching one of his previous books on
Roberto Clemente and and the very
important season 1961 the Pittsburgh
Pirates went on and won the World Series
against the New York Yankees and as he
was reading the sports sections going
through and looking at these stories
about Clemente he kept seeing these
incredible stories on every page about
the Rome 1960 Olympics about young
Cassius Clay the boxer from the United
States about Rayford Johnson and Wilma
Rudolph and he kept reading all the
stories that put this into context this
was the first commercially televised
Olympics this was the first time there
was any inkling that there was
systematic drug use
performance-enhancing drugs in the
Olympics there was a
be a death of a Danish cyclist during
the 1960 Olympics this was the coming of
the equal rights movements the very
start of it in this country for blacks
and for women and that was all coming to
a head at that same time it was the very
very height of the Cold War and there
was a great deal of espionage a great
deal of intrigue in Rome in terms of
trying to find defections on both sides
there is the great - conflict between
nationalist China Red China and which
the nationally nationalist Chinese were
forced to compete under the flag of
either Taiwan or from OSA and when he
kept seeing all of these stories and he
put them all together he knew that he
had not just a book but a book that
could synthesize that time David was
very much born to be a journalist he was
very much born to put words on paper and
to bring them to you his grandfather was
a printer his father was a newspaperman
his mother was a book editor his family
settled in Madison Wisconsin when he was
8 years old and by the time he was a
freshman at the University of Wisconsin
he was writing for the Madison Capitol
Times and sort of press aging his twin
interests he was covering the radical
anti-war movement on the University of
Wisconsin campus and high school sports
in the community so he's a guy that can
do a little bit of everything after
college he did some radio work for a few
years and then landed at the Trenton
Times just up the road just a couple
years after the Times had been purchased
by the Washington Post Company and it
didn't take the post long to realize
what they had and David went to work for
the post in 1977 I believe I could have
that that day wrong and went into their
political reporting he went onto their
national desk in 1992 he was given the
assignment of covering the campaign of
Arkansas Governor William Clinton a guy
who was not given a whole lot of chance
in that election as you recall and David
did pretty good on that assignment and
covering the the campaign in the
election of Clinton he was awarded the
Pulitzer Prize for national reporting it
was the first of two Pulitzer Prizes he
has wanted the post the other was just
this year as part of the team coverage
of the Virginia Tech shooting
in 2007 he's also been a finalist for
the Pulitzer Prize three other times two
times for his newspaper work and once
for his fine narrative about the Vietnam
War they marched in the sunlight
this is his third book when sports and
for someone like me who works in sports
all the time to have people like him
come along
they uplift our profession they raised
the playing field for the rest of us he
follows in a very long line of great
writers who have gone over and done
sports work and you can name
AJ Liebling and and Damon Runyon and
ermine Ernest Hemingway and and Joyce
Carol Oates and David Halberstam and
this guy fits right in with him and
please join me in welcoming to
Philadelphia night great great pleasure
to have David marinus with us
[Applause]
thank you Bob as a cuddly and flattering
but a wonderful summary of the book it
saves me a lot of time I'm on the fifth
day of 34 day book tour it started at
the in Chicago at the Chicago Council of
global affairs and sort of to understand
the the gamut of this book it goes from
there to Mike and the mad dog sports
talk radio in New York are to one of my
favorite moments and in jock talk radio
when I was at a station in Dallas which
I'm going to again and it was two
co-hosts and one guy said to me man this
is the best book I've ever read it was
the Lombardi book and his co-hosts said
well of course Tommy it's the only book
you've ever read I had the pleasure of
speaking here a few years ago for my
book on Roberto Clemente and it was
really one of my favorite moments and
that tour that I still tell the story
we're in the book I was describing how
Clemente for all of his wonderful
attributes was not a saint by any means
and that at one point in fact outside of
the stadium in Philadelphia he had
punched out a 19-year old kid who was
trying to get an autograph Roberto
thought he was trying to accost him and
he he hit him in the face and knocked a
couple of his teeth out so I was telling
that story to say the you know the
Clemente was human and then after I
finished three people in the line as
they were signing books said well
Clemente was of course write him this
guy was from Philadelphia you know as
Bob said I sort of backed into this book
I was researching Clemente and just saw
those amazing names but I really wasn't
sure that I wanted to write another
sports book at that time not that I you
know sort of make that great of a
distinction between sports and politics
I think honestly that politics can be
trivial or important
and sports can be trivial or important
they both can be toy departments or they
can be very very revealing about human
nature and that's what I look for in
each of those themes but but in any case
I just finished Clemente and I wasn't
thinking that I've want to do another
sports book but but it really was just
hit me over the head those names Cassius
Clay Rafer Johnson Wilma Rudolph Abbie
beep akela and I couldn't get them out
of my head and I had remembered the 1960
Olympics I'm 58 years old
I just turned 11 when those Olympics
began in August of 1960 my profoundest
memory my only really vivid memory has
nothing to do with either any of those
four I do remember Cassius Clay a little
bit I remember one more route off
vividly but the strongest memory I have
is of the India Pakistani field hockey
match and I was just 11 year old kid in
Madison Wisconsin and the Pakistanis won
by an upset and their team gathered in a
huddle after the effort as they were
about to get the gold medals and they
started jumping up and down and chanting
wahoo wahoo Pakistan Pakistan so hearing
this little kid in Madison Wisconsin
dancing around in my living room wahoo
wahoo Pakistan I had no idea about
Pakistan I knew nothing about field
hockey but it just seemed like fun and
that really is my most my strongest
memory of those olympic games what what
sealed the deal for me in terms of
writing this book along with those great
characters I'm always looking for
character drama and a way to illuminate
history sociology and culture and in
those games I truly found all of that
it's it's very true when I first started
telling people that I was writing a book
about the Olympics they would mention
the three that Bob did 1936
staged in Nazi Germany in Berlin right
and you know it as World War 2 and the
Holocaust
were approaching very very important
moment and I write about some of that in
this book because one of the key
characters involved in that in a big no
mineus way Avery Brundage the president
of the International Olympic Committee
in 1960 led the American Olympic
Committee in 1936 I'll get back to that
1968 with Tommie Smith and John Carlos
in the Black Power salute a very vivid
unforgettable moment attitude our
history's right in the the turmoil and
tumult of 1968 that unforgettable year
and then 1972 which we all remember so
vividly with the tragedy of Munich and
Jim McKay's coverage who also is in this
book 1960 was his first Olympics but
1960 to me has nothing no individual
moment quite like those three but more
moments it brings all of it together in
1960 you really see the ushering in of
the modern world for better or worse in
every possible way this was at a moment
of deep tension in the Cold War
right before the Olympics began Gary
Powers the pilot of a u2 reconnaissance
spy plane which had been shot down over
Soviet territory in May of 1960 only a
week before the games began he had been
convicted of espionage in Moscow before
the Olympics ended Nikita Khrushchev the
leader of the Soviet Union sailed from
the Baltic to New York for that famous
moment at the United Nations where he
pounded his fists and railed against the
West some of you might think he powdered
his shoe it's a it's a he didn't and the
great biographers in the last five years
of essentially documented that he did
not know what's most fascinating about
that is there's no videotape of it so
you can't you know it's all based on
eyewitness reports anyway he did pound
his fist and that was the that was the
tension between the Soviet Union and
United States at that time but it was
being played out throughout the world in
Africa 14 countries were getting their
independence that very summer and such
fertile territory in the propaganda war
between East and West nobody knew which
way many of those countries would go
would they go with the Soviets or with
America and that had a residence in the
United States because of the civil
rights movement in its early stages in
1960 and how that related to our foreign
policy in in Europe Germany was less
than a year before the Berlin Wall and
there was intense questions about
whether West Germany would get the bomb
whether the Soviets would would try to
invade the u.s. army was in force in
Berlin and in one of those Orwellian
moments as the Olympic Games were being
played out East Germany closed its
border to Westerners they wouldn't allow
West Berliners in the East East Berlin
during those games as thousands of East
Germans were attempting to flee in Asia
it was going on at that time the the to
China's dispute this was only 13 years
after bouts of time took over in
mainland China and Chiang kai-shek
brought his government to the islands of
Taiwan and Formosa there was it in
Chiang kai-shek was trying to persuade
Eisenhower still to invade the mainland
the Presidential Debates of that year
between John Kennedy and Richard Nixon
centered much of it on China and what
the United States would do to defend the
islands of Taiwan and Formosa questions
about the little island some of you
might remember of Como and Matsu and
whether if they were bombed by the
mainland what would the United States
response be so all over the world in
Africa Asia Europe and the United States
you could see all of those tensions and
they all came to bear on the Olympics
Rome was teeming with spy
there were attempts at defection the not
it was not just a battle of metal counts
but of of lives and people as well and
as I was researching this book I
discovered one of the most amazing
stories that had not been told was about
the American sprinter David sim a
medical student at Duke University who
was a sprinter in the mid fifties he was
four briefly considered the fastest man
in the world he was injured before the
56 games in Melbourne and then made a
comeback and made the United States team
in 1960 Tim had was a very intelligent
guy he'd been on a State Department tour
before Washington knew him and knew of
him a few days before the track and
field team left for Rome he was
approached by an American intelligence
agent who said can you come with me to
Washington we'd like to talk to you they
flew down to Washington put one into a
room they took out a dossier of a Soviet
long jumper named Igor Terrell Van Essen
and said this man you know is very
westernized he loves jazz he's learning
English he was in Philadelphia in 1959
for the second ever dual track meet
between the Soviets and the Americans
the first was in Moscow in 1958 the
second was right here in 59 Igor was
here he loved being in America and
American agents were watching him and
thought that he was ready to defect so
they asked Dave sim whether he would
help out in that endeavor him you know
said of course I'll do what I can
they befriended one another in Rome
which was not hard the athletes could
very easily mix as a matter of fact the
Soviet and American track and field
teams held a practice session together
the Soviet team came to visit the
Americans at their compound in a village
so there was a lot of interaction sim
and taro vanessi and went out to dinner
one night and we're talking about the
relative merits of the Western life and
the Soviet life and the plan was that at
the second dinner
an American agent would show up and
close the deal as they both described it
to me first Dave sim he said I didn't
know this agent by anything other than
that name mr. wolf that's what everybody
called him and mr. wolf was supposed to
come midway through the dinner and talk
to Igor and and seal the defection so
that Igor and sim both described for me
what happened that night
midway through the dinner mr. wolf
showed up he had studied Igor terra
vanessi and very thoroughly knew that he
had grown up in the in ukraine but was
in fact an armenian that his parents
were Soviet Armenians so mr. wolf
started talking about Armenia and even
talking in the Armenian dialect and this
scared the heck out of Igor taro of an
essay and he jumped from his chair
thought this guy was a double agent and
said Dave sim I trust you I don't trust
and he stormed out so that was the end
of that defection attempt the stories of
this book come from all of the countries
of the those tense times in Germany the
the story can be told from both sides of
the what would be the wall on the East
German side the star of the Olympics was
seventeen-year-old diver named Ingrid
Kramer who won both the springboard and
platform diving in typical fashion of
that era the American writers called her
The Dresden doll and it's really
fascinating to go back and look at the
coverage of women in 1960 I'll talk
about that more later but in terms of of
Ingrid Kramer in that that moniker all
of the women were sort of treated as
sexual sex figures basically because
some of the gymnast when they'd write
about them they'd write their
measurements in the stories which I
don't think he could do with the the
young girl gymnast of today but then the
gymnasts were full-figured and that and
their measurements were reported in the
stories Sports Illustrated did an entire
six page feature before the Olympics on
a Canadian gymnast only because she was
they thought beautiful she finished in
about 20th place but they and and you
can read reports from colonists from the
New York Times to the San Francisco
Chronicle essentially writing about the
women athletes in terms of what they
looked like as opposed to what they
performed like anyway so Ingrid Kramer
was in that mold as The Dresden doll
she had grown up in Dresden Germany when
she was two years old
she had gone through the firebombing of
that city which turned the entire city
into a firestorm as Kurt Vonnegut
explored in slaughterhouse-five probably
a little bit before
Ingrid Kramer's real consciousness but
she it's so deeply etched in her memory
that she told me just two years ago that
she has had dreams her entire life of an
airplane chasing her and that many of
the girls that she grew up with their
hair turned white or gray when they were
5 years old
Ingrid Kramer was one of the stars of
the Olympics she won both of those gold
medals the East Germans treated her as
though she were a conquering hero and
said that her performance was due
primarily or solely to the superiority
of the socialist system she went back to
Dresden and to East Germany and was
treated well became a star coach for the
Dresden women four years thereafter in
the night later in the 1960s the German
East German women became notorious for
the use of testosterone drugs to to
improve the performance particularly of
the women swimmers not the divers it
really doesn't help diving but the
swimmers and it was a horrible horrible
program where many of those girls got
very sick when they became older women
and some of them died and some of them
had had sex change operations because
they were so infused with testosterone
which they were told were merely
vitamins in any case as part of that
when the reunification
of Germany came along all of the East
German coaches were fired and some of
them were put on trial for for their
administering of those illegal drugs
Ingrid Kramer had nothing to do with
that she in diving the drugs weren't
used but when the wall fell she lost her
job and she fell into a deep depression
from what she really has not recovered
and it's one of those interesting sort
of unexpected consequences of what is
essentially a beneficial act for mankind
for Ingrid Kramer it was in in one way
the end of her of her life when that
wall fell on the other side you had
Armin Hari the German sprinter who was
sort of my favorite rapscallion villain
of the book Armin Hari was called the
thief of starts everybody thought he
cheated from the starting gun in fact he
probably didn't they did studies
photographers and videographers of of it
and he just had better reactions than
any other Runner and he could get off
right a couple of hundred to the second
faster than anyone else but Armin Hari
was a jerk he before the before the
hundred meter dash Jesse Owens who was
the star of the 1936 games the one who
sort of personally overcame the entire
notion of Aryan superiority by winning
all those great medals in Nazi Germany a
black American track athlete from Ohio
State in any case Jesse Owens was in
Rome covering the games for a Chicago
newspaper he wanted to speak to Armin
Hari and how he dubbed him said no I
don't have time for the guy and one of
the great lines of Jesse Owens his life
he said I've been snubbed by bigger
jerks before but never by faster ones
in any case Armand Hari was on the take
and on the make and in one of the first
breaches of the code of amateurism he in
1960 was taking money from a shoe
company well actually not one shoe
company but two shoe companies the key
shoe companies of that era were both
German companies Adidas and Puma run by
the dostler brothers the name adidas
comes from Adi Dassler who ran adidas
and Rudy das the ran Puma well the
brothers both were interested in armand
Hari because he was such a great runner
but they didn't know that each of them
were paying him so that Armand Hari ran
100 meter dash wearing Adidas shoes took
them off when on the gold medal stand
with Pumas this was a sign of things to
come with Armand Hari he went on and as
angry Cramer's suffered from from in her
own way Armand Hari got his just
desserts he became an embezzler later
and went to prison stories from Africa
in 1960 South Africa completely
apartheid was still competing in the
Olympics there was a movement just
beginning right then to try to change
that led by a man in South African and
Denis Brutus he formed a committee to
try to pressure the Olympics to live up
to its Creed which is that they don't
discriminate by cholera race or origin
and he started sending letters to Avery
Brundage the president of the IOC and
two others for that effort he was denied
a passport to come to Rome and his
office was invaded and all of his
documents were taken another official
from Great Britain who was supporting
him did get to Rome and got a meeting
with the IOC to try to present the case
the South African argument in 1960 was
that they were trying to integrate their
team
but there were no black athletes good
enough to make the Olympics and every
Brundage and his men bought that
argument at least then four years later
the tumult and change in the world would
make it impossible and finally South
Africa was expelled for several decades
but what was going on on the other side
of Africa and black Africa was 14
nations were getting their independence
that summer and no black African had
ever won a gold medal they were just
starting to compete among the athletes
who came to Rome was an Ethiopian runner
named AB a babe Aquila nobody had heard
of him outside of Ethiopia the utopian
team had about 11 members a bevy boo
Kela came to Rome with a pair of shoes
that didn't fit right so he ditched them
he decided he wouldn't run with shoes
he'd run many times barefoot back in
Ethiopia through the hills so the
marathon is about to begin and the
American it's it starts at the
Capitoline steps in ancient Rome and the
American marathoners Gordon McKenzie
told me that he and Ellen Kelly were
standing on the steps and Mackenzie
looks over and sees this skin and bones
number 11 and a green shirt skinny guy
without any shoes on and he turns to
Ellen Kelly and says well that's one guy
we won't have to worry about
and nobody did until halfway through the
race when word came back that the
barefoot Ethiopian was in first place
was in the lead now he was so unknown
that most of them sports writers called
him Vic ela Beebe they had no idea who
he was and started to try to find out is
the race proceeded this is one of those
incredible symbolic moments that you
can't make up that real life just
presents to you here is a barefoot
Ethiopian running through the streets of
Rome the second half of the race is
along the old Appian Way it's evening
there are Roman sentinels standing along
the way
holding torch lights
the barefoot Ethiopian comes by he's
running through the streets of the
capital city of the nation that had
invaded and bombed his homeland only 25
years earlier Mussolini's army and
Mussolini's army not only had invaded
Ethiopia but they had brought back to
Rome one of the great works of antiquity
from Ethiopia the Aksum obelisk and they
placed it in the center of Rome and here
comes a Beebe makyla running past the
Aksum obelisk that had been stolen from
his homeland he just takes off and he
wins by with a record time for the
marathon running in the darkness in bare
feet ending at the arch of Constantine
another of the symbols of the country
that had defeated his homeland and as
one of his countrymen said it took him
an army of a million to defeat
Ethiopia and one Ethiopian did feed
Italy now as a BVB Kela in 1960 the
whole notion of what was going on in
Africa was deeply connected to what was
happening in the United States with a
civil rights movement here you had the
United States presenting itself as the
beacon of Liberty around the world at
the same time that millions of its own
people including some of its greatest
athletes were treated as second-class
citizens
it's an inarguable fact the Soviets kept
pounding away at that and what was it
what was the answer so the one of the
fascinating sort of obvious lessons and
rest respect but hit me over the head as
I was reporting the book is that the
Cold War on that sense had a beneficial
effect on civil rights in the United
States because of that obvious hypocrisy
it forced the Eisenhower administration
the State Department the Kennedy
administration to act more assertively
not assertively enough but more so than
they might have had had not been that
that such blatant problem they were
having in their foreign policy in Africa
and third world countries because of the
segregation at home as in one of the
small ways that the United States tried
to combat that in Rome was to name Rafer
Johnson
a great decathlete to carry the American
flag at the opening ceremonies now Rafer
Johnson totally deserved that honor
he was the greatest athlete of that era
and he was not only that but also a man
of tremendous dignity he was the captain
of the team all of the of his teammates
on the u.s. squad respected him he
deserved the honor but it was also he
also knew that he was being manipulated
to some extent that he was being used by
the powers that be to try to present a
different face to the world and that's a
conundrum that blacks in the United
States have often faced about the
expectations of the people in power of
how they should behave or how they can
be used but blacks what choices do they
have so Rafer Johnson faced it knew the
hypocrisy of it but said to himself the
way that I can improve civil rights what
I can do is to first win the gold medal
be the best athlete I can be and second
to comport myself with dignity and pride
and show the world who I am and so he
agreed to carry the American flag he
also won the gold medal and that was
another one of the most thrilling
moments of these Olympics some of the
sports writers kind of had I've always
had fun making fun of the decathlon is
sort of a an effort in mediocrity
because in truth they're ten events over
two days and the athletes who perform in
those are not at the top world-class in
any single event or maybe one but rarely
more than that but nonetheless it
requires such incredible durability and
dexterity and Rafer Johnson was the best
in the world along with CK Young from
Taiwan or Formosa which we talked about
earlier and in fact because of the
International Olympics committees
decision to force Taiwan to call itself
by that name or Formosa but not the
Republic of China which is how they like
to be called there was a backlash
against that decision Avery Brundage the
same man who was pushed
a conservative arch-conservative
Republican from Chicago but suddenly
being called a communist sympathizer
because the Olympic Committee had said
Taiwan is Taiwan not China there was an
effort to boycott the Olympics the State
Department was pushing Taiwan to boycott
the Olympics rather than accede to that
nomenclature the reason they didn't is
because they had this great athlete CK
Young who they knew would win him a
medal he was a teammate of Rafer
Johnson's at UCLA they trained together
they were very close friends and they
were almost equal as decathletes Rafer
was better at the javelin throw the shot
put the discus CK was better at some of
the sprints in the pole vault and it all
came down to the final event the metric
mile the 1500 meter race on the second
night in the evening not only were they
teammates but they had the same coach
duckie Drake the UCLA coach was there in
the stadium in the front row and CK yang
was a better miler his best time was 13
seconds better than Rafer Johnson's best
time Rayford Johnson had to win by 10
seconds or less and he would get the
gold medal because he was in front going
into that race so before the race starts
rafer Johnson walks over to his coach
duckie Drake and he said duckie what
should I do
CK is a better mother than I am how
would you suggest I run this race and
ducky said well look CK is a better
mother than you but you just have to
stick with them and when it comes to the
bell lap CK is going to turn around and
you have to be there and he's gonna try
to take off and you have to stay with
them and you can break his will
psychologically so Rafer Johnson comes
back CK young walks over to ducky Drake
ducky how can I win this race but he
suggests well ravers are better miler
than you are but when it comes to the
last lap he's gonna try to be at your
side and you just got to take off and
break his will he was like a chess
player playing both sides so the race
begins and Rafe Rick Johnson had one
advantage
he knew he was retiring after this race
the decathlon is the most exhausting
Enterprise you can imagine five events
each day for two days and this was the
lat and ending with the mile which is a
brutal race this was the last time the
Rafer would ever have to do it and
that's what he kept telling himself as
the race progressed I hate this damn
race I never have to do it again just
keep you in there keep running hang in
there I'll never have to do it again so
they get through the last lap just as
ducky Drake predicted CK turned around
looked over his shoulder and there's
Rafer right at his side right behind him
smiling
rafer said to me I was smiling out of
pain and I was acting but I knew it that
I had to be there and I had to smile and
it worked it did break CK's well he
tried to excel all right he couldn't he
couldn't get away from Rafer rafer
finished close enough behind CK just a
few feet behind that he won the gold
medal and as they crossed the finish
line they collapsed into each others
arms now the whole Olympic ideal of of
athletes competing to the best of
ability and having nothing to do with
the politics of the world is completely
bogus but there are in every Olympics
these wonderful moments and that was one
of them the black athlete from the
United States in the Asian from Taiwan
really close friends collapsing in each
other's arms and the photographs of that
moment are authentic statements of
sportsmanship and Rafer told me later
that as great as he felt and relieved as
he felt about winning that race he felt
almost as bad that CK had to lose
the story of the Olympics that that
really drew me in the deepest had to do
with Wilma Rudolph in the tiger bells of
Tennessee State University Wilma Rudolph
became a star in those Olympics she won
three gold medals these were the first
televised Olympics so the whole world
saw her we didn't see her live there was
no live coverage yet the the satellites
were an up for transatlantic
communications yet as a matter of fact
there the video and film was literally
put in canisters and the belly of
commercial jets and flown back to New
York and sometimes shown that night if
an event happened early enough in the
morning because of the time difference
usually shown the next day Jim McKay who
we talked about earlier was the host of
those games he wasn't even in Rome he
was back in New York City at a studio in
Grand Central Station the film would
come in he'd be sitting there at his
typewriter pounding out a script as was
being edited looking at the Encyclopedia
Britannica to find out where a country
was but it was televised which was not
what happened in Melbourne in 1956 and
here came wilma rudolph this beautiful
lithe runner with a charismatic
personality and she stole the show she
had both grace about her and a story
that were incredible
she was the she was one of 22 children
from the family from Clarksville
Tennessee she'd had probably had
childhood polio that's what all the
reports say I couldn't find the records
at the Meharry Medical Center where she
was treated but it appears that she had
polio she certainly had scarlet fever in
any case one of her legs had been
slightly withered and she wore and out
of joint and she wore braces for three
years she went to Melbourne in 1956 as a
16 year old barely 16 won a bronze medal
there came back to high school in
Clarksville
and got pregnant so that by the time she
got to Rome she did overcome polio and
teenage pregnancy and won three gold
medals and led the tiger Belles to the
incredible moments of the Olympics and
as amazing as her story as the tiger
Belle story really resonates even deeper
with me the tiger valves were the
women's track team at Tennessee State
University in Nashville Tennessee and
historically black college this was long
before title nine there were no
scholarships for women athletes then
there were very few programs for women
particularly in track and field
there was no distance beyond 880 meters
that they were allowed to run was
considered unladylike the marathon
didn't come to women until 1984 so it
was in that situation that the tiger
Belles lived and worked furthermore
there were black women in the Jim Crow
South in 1960 their coach at Temple
didn't even have an office at Tennessee
State he had to share his office with
his wife who was the postmaster of the
little school he had nothing to offer
the women except his training they
didn't even have a bus to travel the
different meets they'd take a clunky old
station wagon and couldn't stop for for
4 meals so they packed peanut butter and
jelly sandwiches were afraid to stop at
service stations to go to the bathroom
they'd say it's time to hit the fields
when they had to go and they'd pull over
to the side of the road they came out of
that nothingness to create the greatest
women's track and field team in history
and really paved the way for so many
women athletes to follow and there was
one last moment involving Wilma Rudolph
that that I'll end with it was after she
won the gold medal she came back to
Nashville and her hometown of
Clarksville wanted to hold a parade for
her everybody loved Wilma Rudolph I
haven't even mentioned yet Cassius Clay
who was the white heavyweight champion
and the reason is on purpose he wasn't a
major figure in these Olympics he became
the most famous athlete in the world for
years 3 4 years later but in 1960 he was
just an obstructing everybody else on
the team crazy with his boasting he had
the same personality in 1960 they would
have later but none of the meaning
behind it he was afraid to fly they had
to give him sleeping pills to get him on
the plane over to Rome they didn't put
him to sleep he after all his way over
there he'd met everyone in the village
but there was one person he really
wanted to meet and that was Wilma
Rudolph he was head over heels for her
that's was everybody as were the town
fathers of Clarksville because of what
she had done winning these gold medals
so they said they wanted to hold a
parade and banquet for her when she got
back to Clarksville and she said no you
can't do it unless the parade and the
banquet are integrated and they ceded to
that request they had really no choice
and her guts to say that brought about
the first time in Clarksville history
that black and white officials and black
and white families
sat together in the armory of
Clarksville to honor Wilma Rudolph thank
you very much
and I'd be happy to take questions on
this book or any book I think you're
supposed to get the microphone there it
is a brilliant book and we appreciate
your insights one question from more of
the political world of 1960 did you have
a chance to meet with mister Andreotti
who you mentioned twice in the book to
get his perspective on the Italians
hosting it in light of him still being
alive today
mister Andreotti who was the defense
minister of Italy and the president of
the Italian Olympic Committee was still
alive when I went to Rome we had a
meeting set up with him but an emergency
happened so I didn't get to talk to him
but I did spend three weeks in Rome and
interviewed several of the athletes
including Livio Baruti another star who
won the 200 meter dash and also was in
love with Wilma Rudolph and told me that
if only he could have gotten alone with
her he could have consummated their
platonic relationship and many of the
great Italian sports writers who were
just starting off then and several other
officials so I I got a good sense of the
Italian perspective and try to present
that in the book there was one moment
during my research in Rome that I'll
never forget this was only 15 years
after World War two so the Rome Olympics
in a sense were really Italy's coming
out from under the shadows of the
Mussolini regime in the fascist era the
area where that most of the Olympics
were held where the Stadio Olimpico was
had been much of it have been built by
Mussolini and had been called the Foro
Mussolini until they changed it to the
400 italico but etched into the
sidewalks as you walked to the stadium
or still all these signs honoring El
Duque it was everywhere the the this was
only 15 years earlier it's like today
going back to the early Clinton
administration it's not that long ago
for America
World War two by 1960 seemed ancient
because America was forgetting and
trying to move forward and was you know
in that just look forward mode I mean
some of the athletes hadn't even been
born when these Olympics when when the
World War two ended Donna Deever own of
the swimmer was only 13 she was born
after World War two but in Italy and in
Europe these Olympic or two was still
very much on their minds and these
Olympics had something to do with that
and so we came to Rome and we went into
the assembly hall where Audrey Adi and
his men would meet every morning before
the Olympics began on the two sides of
the of this assembly hall were these in
1960 they were covered up by green felt
when we got there only a couple of years
earlier the felt had been taken down and
what was behind it were these incredible
frightening murals that were called the
apotheosis of fascism with Mussolini in
the center surrounded by the black
shirts and all of these symbols of the
fascist era so it was still there in
1960 yes sir
I forget what was her afterlife thanks
for asking
Wilma Rudolph married the father of her
first child Yolanda who came to who
lived with her sister and then her
parents for a little while and then came
to live with Wilma she became a coach
and an inspirational speaker and died at
an early age at 52 of a brain tumor and
when I was interviewing her coach Edie
temple we were at we spent several hours
in this little restaurant in North
Nashville called sweats barbecue very
close to the Tennessee State campus and
that temple was describing for me how it
was right there at sweats right over in
that corner over there where he last
spent his last hours with Wilma Rudolph
and they'd walked around the Tennessee
State track which was 2/3 of a track and
full of cleat marks because the football
team had practiced there and they talked
about their lives and then they came
over to sweats and mr. sweat had carried
her tray over to that table you know she
would die three days later and that was
his last memories of Wilma Rudolph as a
teenager remember hearing about Avery
Brundage for quite a long period of time
how powerful was he and why danijon
stayed that way for so long and could
you talk about some of the colorful
aspects yes it's all in my book and
thank you for asking this this book
we've so many things together that I can
never put them all in 25 minutes speech
but but Avery Brundage is often the one
I talk about for those of you don't know
him he he was decathlete himself at the
University of Illinois in the 1912
Olympics the ones won by Jim Thorpe
Brundage had been responsible or part of
the movement later to remove Jim
Thorpe's medals because he'd been a
semi-pro baseball player later
Brundage's Brundage was a hypocrite and
an anti-semite in a man who believed
that the Olympic movement was bigger
than any ideology or religion sometimes
that would make you have him make
decisions that perhaps were right often
wrong but the decision that in my mind
edges him forever was in 1936 when he
was the president of the American
Olympic Committee and as I was
researching every Brundage at the
archive at the University of Illinois I
came across all these letters that he
was exchanging with with German
officials as those Olympics were
approaching and he was writing about how
it was a cabal of a Jewish conspiracy to
try to boycott those Olympics and that
he would appreciate it if the German
officials would send to him the
clippings showing what the real good
things that the Nazis were doing because
the American press was portraying them
as evil people and that couldn't be the
case so he he prevailed there was no
boycott boycotts are always debatable no
matter what's going on and in a 1936
it's a fascinating debate because the
Americans went over there
led by Jesse Owens who won all those
medals and so it had a fascinating
effect to have had a lot of those
Olympics to go on it certainly didn't
change anything with Nazi Germany with
World War two and the the horrors of the
Holocaust still to come when Avery
Brundage came back from from Germany in
1936 after the Olympics he took part in
a rally at Madison Square Garden
attended by 19,000 German Americans a
German American Bund and at that rally
he came up and gave a speech extolling
the virtues of Hitler and the Nazis and
saying that America had much to learn
from that
that was the every Brundage in 1936
every Brundage went on to become the
head of the International Olympic
Committee
he was very astute politically every
everybody sort of hated him but he
always knew how to survive and he
survived longer as the head of the
Olympic Committee than anyone else the
athletes in particular hated him
they called him slavery Avery and in
part it was because of the draconian
rules of amateurism in that era like so
many other parts of sports it begins
with the athletes being completely used
and abused and then it proceeds from
there to them getting their freedom and
then people thinking that it's excessive
when they become multimillionaires and
spoiled brats but it starts with with
the abuse and slavery Avery was part of
that he was he thought of himself as a
king he was in the in the Olympic
movement when he was leading it the the
Executive Committee of the International
Olympic Committee for all of these lords
and Dukes and princes Avery Brundage
himself was not one he was a self-made
millionaire businessman from Chicago but
he liked to behave like a lord hit the
vice-president of the IOC during that
era was the Marquess of Exeter from
Great Britain who many of you will
recognize as a character in the movie
Chariots of Fire
he was the hurdler the the upper-class
hurdler who set up champagne glasses on
each of the hurdles outside of his manse
and would practice running over the
hurdles so that the champagne bottles
wouldn't or glasses wouldn't drop anyway
the Marquess was the vice president but
it was easy for people like that to
uphold this sort of nineteenth-century
notion of amateurism they're so rich of
course you compete and don't worry about
money but most athletes come out of
poverty and hunger and it's a far
different situation for them and you had
these preposterous examples of the
application of pure amateurism where for
instance Lee Calhoun a great hurdler of
that era who had
the gold medal in 1956 in Melbourne and
would win it again in Rome in 1960 was
suspended for a year in between because
he and his college sweetheart Gwen got
married on the TV show bride and groom
and that was they were said to he was
said to be a professional because they
took some some presents some wedding
presents on that television show and he
never would have been on the show unless
he were a famous hurdler of course most
of the other no one else on that show
had ever been a famous or even an
athlete in any case it was that kind of
imposition of quote/unquote amateurism
that that led to the reaction to it
and Brundage was trying to say he was
always trying to sort of hold the walls
for better or worse often for worse
sometimes for better you know he's
trying to hold back the coming of the
modern era and he he survived for a long
time he would give all these moralistic
speeches about self responsibility at
the same time he was one of the great
philanderers of all time he had
thousands of paramours and a mistress
who he had a whole separate family
unbeknownst to anybody Intel Sports
Illustrated uncovered it in the 1970s so
he was a really fascinating man
sometimes he would make the right
decision like I'm Taiwan and mainland
China I try to give him his humanity in
this book it's not easy yes wait
some really impressed with the way you
think about culture and politics as well
as sports and I'm wondering given the
current state of the Olympics in China
and the incredible repression by the
Chinese government against Tibet that
the button people and their own people
over the years as they have one of the
worst records of abuse of their own
civilians in the world how do you see
these all of the games coming up now
these games will be as political as any
games they always are they always
operate on two tracks one is the
athletic events and one is the politics
it's one of the rare times when the
entire world is in one place at the same
time and so it's inevitable there will
be some amazing performances I'm sure in
Beijing you know just the story so far
I've Dara Torres the 41 year old swimmer
is amazing and I'm sure there'll be you
know Phelps will win seven or eight gold
medals and there'll be all kinds of
stories about the events and they'll be
very noteworthy and terrific stories but
I think in for history what will be
remembered is how China handles these
Olympics there will be the Chinese
introduction into the 20th century which
they think will be their century for
better or worse and you're right they
have you know human rights pollution
Tibet the thousands of journalists from
around the world who will be there
poking around and trying to in a nation
that is accustomed to complete control I
don't know how it's going to go but I
know that that's how it will be
remembered for better or worse and
[Music]
history will call these the Chinese
Olympics it won't be remembered for the
athletes
was didn't want to didn't want to steer
the conversation in to my own agenda but
I read your book about marching into
sunlight because I was in Wisconsin
during the riots huh
and I don't know you probably run into
people all the time so I just that's one
of the reasons I came down here is take
you meet you and see you could you say
anything about the way this immersion
your journalism your kind of us sort of
wading into these parts of history and
immersing emergent immersing yourself in
it in this very intimate and personal
way with individuals that were also
immersed in it and I wonder how that
affects you and you know it I find a
very sort of awe-inspiring that you do
that and you're kind of a witness that
brings these stories back to the world
but if you could say if you were shot
how how that works for you yeah well the
the book that you're mentioning they
marched into sunlight I know I'll never
not write another book like that again
it was the most psychologically
rewarding and depleting and difficult
book I could undertake I'm from Madison
was for those of you don't know this
book takes place in October of 1967 and
it's about the war in the anti war which
were two very different worlds about the
same thing so half the book is the first
riot on a college campus where the
police came in and bashed the heads of
students a protest against Dow Chemical
Company the makers of napalm at the same
time in Vietnam battalion from the 1st
Infantry Division was walking out on a
search-and-destroy mission and got
destroyed with 60 men killed and 60
wounded out of 140 in the in the
battalion and so I've brought these two
worlds together and interwove them in
the book and I moved to
Madison for part of the book where I'm
from I hadn't been living there in 32
years and some of the subjects from that
part of the story were still in Madison
and I found others from around the
country and a lot of the archival
documents and tried to recreate a moment
that I knew pretty well because I was a
freshman at Wisconsin that that October
although I wasn't participants on the
outside of the riots wearing my first
blue jean jacket and sort of was
affected as many freshmen were by what
they saw that day affected forever the
Vietnam side of the story I knew nothing
about until I started this book I had
never been to Vietnam I was not a
Vietnam veteran that part of the book
will live with me
more deeply than anything I've ever done
because I became a witness for all these
soldiers who endured the worst that man
can do to man and they felt that the
government had lied about that battle
and that the general was given a Silver
Star who wasn't even there there were so
many different aspects to it that and
they were caught in a horrible ambush
surrounded on three sides outnumbered
nine to one they all thought they would
die so in every possible respect that
day is so deeply yet in their memories
that defines them too now and so dealing
with those men and and winning their
trust and then having to to present them
to the world was very difficult but as I
said incredibly rewarding and that's
what I tried to do you know just fine
you know this with this book I thought
that Rafer Johnson and Wilma Rudolph and
the coach had temple had been
overshadowed in history by people like
Muhammad Ali and I wanted them to get
their due and so that's why I spent so
much time with people like that thank
you
what I was thinking I just wanted to
know what Rafer Johnson is doing now
Rayford Johnson is 72 years old he looks
like he could win the decathlon in
Beijing he's an incredible shape he was
part of the Kennedy entourage after that
for a large part of his life he went
into acting was sort of a b-list actor
in several movies he was deeply involved
in the Special Olympics and that's still
what he's doing I the first my first
interview with him was at the office of
the Special Olympics in Los Angeles for
those of you who don't know this story
he was so close to the Kennedys that he
was in the kitchen of the Ambassador
Hotel the night that Bobby Kennedy was
assassinated and if you listen to the
audio tapes you can hear someone yelling
get the gun ray forget the gun and it
was Rafer Johnson and the football
player rosey Grier who tackled Sirhan
Sirhan and took the gun away from him
and something that's really hard to
believe that it happened but it did
rafer put the gun in his sport coat and
forgot that he had it and for some
reason the cops didn't sort of keep
everybody in there until they found the
gun so he walked he went home with the
gun in his pocket and we found it a
couple of days later and drove over to
the police station and turned to do yes
ma'am
I've always been curious of how
professional basketball got into the
Olympics it seems as though it's they're
doing it backwards professional
basketball thanks for asking that
question another story that I didn't get
to tonight involved what I consider to
be the real dream team which was the
1960 basketball team where the backcourt
was Oscar Robertson and Jerry West now I
don't think there's ever been a better
backcourt in history they were both
college players Oscar Robertson from the
University of Cincinnati coming out of
Crispus Attucks High School in
Indianapolis and Jerry West from the
University of West Virginia coming out
of little small-town Cabin Creek in West
Virginia and they were the co-captains
of the team that team had for future
Hall of Famers those two plus Walt
Bellamy and Jerry Lucas and they were
all college kids and they want every
game by an average of 30 points but the
world was up and the world was changing
and as many sports became the walls of
amateurism and professionalism merged in
many sports in the Olympics and
basketball was one of those and and the
United States decided that after they'd
lost couple of times that they couldn't
stand that anymore so they started
bringing in the professionals and that
brought the 1992 dream team of Michael
Jordan and Magic Johnson and Larry Bird
and then the team we have going to
Beijing led by Kobe Bryant and LeBron
James and the the great irony is that
even the professionals don't always win
now you know they didn't win in four
years ago and they might not win in
Beijing but it's just a fact of life
today I mean the the Olympics are
completely commercialized this is not
the United States basketball team that
you're rooting for it's than they
key team that you're rooting for you
know they're wearing Nike shoes they're
wearing Nike uniforms last week they all
gathered in New York at a you know event
sponsored by Nike and that's what it is
that's the way it works today one more
okay you mentioned a little bit about
starting blocks and they're to go back
and look at tapes to figure out to the
start on your timer to jump the gun I
read something in the paper about the
Swimming days they were still using stop
watches back then you talked about the I
forget her name the woman who ran the
marathon barefoot and my question is
about sort of a technology theme that
runs through the Olympics it's sort of
what was going on in 1968 both the way
reporters filed the reports the way
athletes trained or didn't train and
then the equipment that they used yeah
this was right at the cusp of change and
you know that's that fits into the whole
theme of the book that you could see the
modern world emerging at that point but
it was still the old world in many
respects you know from the archaic
nature of the television to the to the
swimming the way swimming was judged in
that era I was before electronic
touchpads there were three judges
leaning over the end the finish line of
each swimmer who had stop watches and
then there were judges on the sides of
the pool on these bleachers
for the the event that I write about in
the book it was the 100-meter freestyle
the American Lance Larsen against the
Australian Jon Devon finishing very
close together the stopwatch judges all
had Devitt with a time that was
two-tenths of a second faster to
hundreds of a second faster the the
judges on the side said it was a tie and
there's this old official judge whose
way
the background somewhere and he declares
that Devitt the Australian is the winner
and to make that and he had the
authority to do it to make that possible
they had to change the times for Lance
Larsson because he couldn't have a
faster time and lose and that that's the
way it was in that era so you know I
mean in so many ways everything was just
changing then the next Olympics they did
have the touch pads and for better and
worse everything was changing thank you
very much